so we've got two figures right over here
and i want to think about how much space
they take up on your screen and this
idea of how much space something takes
up on a surface this idea is
area so right when you look at it it
looks pretty clear that this purple
figure takes up more space on my screen
than this blue figure but how do we
actually measure it how do we actually
know how much more
area this purple figure takes up than
this blue one
well one way to do it would be to define
a unit amount of area so for example i
could create a square right over here
and the square
whatever units we're using we could say
it's a one unit so it's width right over
here is one unit
and its height right over here is one
unit
we could call this a unit square
a unit
square
and so one way to measure the area of
these figures is to figure out how many
unit squares i could cover this thing
with without overlapping and while
staying in the boundaries so let's try
to do that let's try to cover each of
these with unit squares and then and
essentially we'll have a measure of area
so i'll start with this blue one
so we could put one
two three
three
four
five
five unit squares and let me write this
down so we got
one two three
four
five unit squares and i could draw the
boundary between those unit squares a
little bit clearer
so we have five
unit squares
and so we could say that this figure
right over here has an area
the area is five we could say five unit
squares the more typical way of saying
it is that you have five square
five square
units
that's the area over here now let's do
the same thing with this purple figure
so with the purple figure
i could put one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
10
of these unit squares i can cover it
they're not overlapping or i'm trying
pretty close to not make them overlap
you see you can fit 10 of them and let
me draw the boundary between them so you
can make them a little you can see it a
little bit clearer so
that's the boundary between my unit
squares
between my unit squares so i think there
you go
and we can count them we have one two
three four five six 7 8
9 10. so we could say the area here let
me actually divide these with the black
boundary too it makes a little bit
clearer than that blue
so the area here for the purple figure
we could say so the area here
is equal to 10
10
square
10 square units
so what we have here we have an idea of
how much space does something take up on
a surface
and you could eyeball it say hey this
takes up more space but now we've come
up with a way of measuring it we can
define a unit square here it's a one
unit by one unit in the future we'll see
that it could be a it could be a unit
centimeter it could be a one centimeter
by one centimeter square could be a one
meter by one meter square could be a one
foot by one foot square but then we can
use that to actually measure the area of
things this thing has an area of five
square units this thing has an area of
10 square units so this one we can
actually say is twice has twice the area
the purple figure had twice the area
it's 10 square units as the blue figure
it takes up twice the amount of space on
the screen